I've got a shape for you Brady if you've
got a shape you want to start putting it
together so I've got just these are
copies of the same shape and I'm
allowing myself to flip them over that's
quite nice I have covered the boundary
of my original shape with copies of the
same so we might ask what can I do that
again keeping going with the shape if I
had enough of these pieces I could sort
of now I can put some things round and
maybe I can I can sort of get myself
into trouble
I couldn't get stuck so but maybe if I
work hard enough I could put another
loop round and maybe another one maybe I
could go on forever maybe not this tile
was discovered by someone called Casey
man he actually started knowing that
this is a tile where you cannot go on
forever and the way we describe that is
this is an unbalanced tile so if you
look at it there's one part of this tile
this piece here we've got an arc of a
circle where I can fit something on and
it can serve but I can only fit the
pieces of the tile that curve in onto
the piece that curves out now all these
arcs are sort of multiples of a sixth of
a circle and so if I sort of look round
this
this shape here I've got the positive
piece the convex piece and that has four
and then here I have concave and that's
actually two there I have one there here
we have three and here we have one so if
you notice the negatives one two three
four five six seven the positive zone
four and so as I keep on going the
amount of negative relative to positive
is going to grow and grow well and at
some point it's going to overwhelm
things this is a tile we're gonna have
to stop at some point and the time where
we stop the number of rings we can do is
something called the huge number so
what's the H number for that shape so
the huge number for this shape is is
three and here is something where we can
show those rings and so no matter how
hard you try
you can't go further than that with this
particular time we can ask what what
other numbers can be heat numbers
what about circle what's the huge number
of a circle so when you surround it it
has to also be touched at every edge
right you really need to surround it
profit possible so the circle I've just
written at each number it's zero another
simple example is the square you could
do that forever yeah so the huge numbers
infinity this shape here lies somewhere
between the circle with zero and the
square with infinity and obviously
complete rings they have to be whole
numbers there's a fairly old example
which looks like this and this is an
early example and it has he's number one
so that means I can cover the boundary
of this tile completely with copies of
this type once but then I can't go any
further we can have examples where you
can do two rings
three rings like the example we started
with and four rings you can even get up
to doing five whole rings and you can
see this shape does it and you're seeing
how this could be quite a complex
operation here that this is not the
natural way necessarily you might feel
the obvious way you can get yourself
into trouble in all sorts of places as
you put things on and in fact this tile
with each number five also discovered by
Casey man is the world record holder and
just to give you a sense this is not an
old problem because even he Schnur to
was only found in 1991 the conjecture is
all he's numbers all whole numbers are
the he's number for some time that's
what we believe yet we only know
examples up to five so if I said 4622
there could be a shape out there that
will do it and then stop yeah we believe
that would be the case this is linked to
some other tiling problems but we sort
of had no idea how you'd even start it
to prove that or find find examples how
does a problem like this progress this
isn't like the Riemann hypothesis at
where everyone wants to solve it this is
yeah this is a problem which now has a
little bit of an knowledge about it so
if you were to if you were to make
significant progress on it then people
would look at and take note although
significant progress is probably
something a bit more than saying oh I've
just found a tile with each number six
and so both of the two examples from
from Casey man this example with with
each number three and the one with each
number five they are both part of a sort
of more general study that he did
looking at what you could do with poly
Hex's where you stick together hexagons
and then mix and markings on the side it
might be that you could get some rich
structure from that yo you could then
get a result where you say I can do
every even number up to 50 and then that
might be might be a more interesting
result the other
think it's related to is a problem
called the Einstein problem
Einstein as in one tile and that asks if
there is a single tile Einstein in
German so it's a bad pun which will tile
the plane but not periodically so all
the infinite tilings we know so far a
periodic no we have things like the
Penrose tiling but that has two
different shapes so you take your shape
you put it together in all possible ways
and you can cover the whole plane but
there none of them which are like the
squares the tiling of squares which I
can just pick up shift and put down and
it's the same everywhere when I do that
so that with the Einstein problem you
you would find a single tile that can
create tilings of the plane but not
periodically you're asking for tilings
that will only produce non periodic
tiling there is a slight cheat with the
Einstein problem
Joan Taylor and Tasmania did her math
degree and then raised a family but
always had an interest in mathematics
and spent in particular this problem and
so about ten years ago now she found a
single tile that has this property the
only problem is that it's not a
connected tile I can draw some path we
might set in here this is a connected
object I can if I'm somewhere on this
island I can get anywhere else but
imagine if I say well my island is
officially going to be this piece and
this piece now I can only move them
around together I can't move them freely
they you know they stay in the same
places so that's a single shape but with
two pieces and so she found a particular
shape that has this property you can see
it there and this will only tile non
periodically
but yeah just like cheated it's it's a
really nice result because this was a
problem that was like fifty or sixty
years old I say often in mathematics
when you can't solve a problem for long
enough even a solution it's a little bit
of a cheat can be a useful inflammation
and it's a very valid cheat if that
makes sense because you do have one
shape that you can move
round together it's just the way it's
defined
I couldn't laser cut it which is why why
I'm not soaking dead mountain is a
gripping account of the so called
Dyatlov pass incident this is a true
story from 1959 when nine young hikers
who were pretty experienced mysteriously
died in the Ural Mountains here in the
Soviet Union now I don't want to give
too much away but it's one of the great
mysteries and it's still a very famous
tale in Russia and it's the most recent
book I've listened to on audible I
really recommend it it's fascinating
well told and it's read by the author
Don eik in a kind of dry but really
engrossing way audible at the sponsor of
today's video and they've got an
unmatched range of books I personally
really like mountaineering ones but
there's always something you'll find to
your taste
joining audible means every month you
get one credit and you can use on an
audiobook plus two audible originals
from a changing selection of shows that
you can't get anywhere else and if you
ever download a book that say you don't
like you can exchange it no charge no
questions asked it's a really great deal
and it's really easy to do to get your
first audiobook with a free 30-day trial
visit audible.com slash numberphile or
texts numberphile to 500 500 there are
the details on the screen audible.com
slash numberphile or that SMS the word
numberphile to 500 500 and my
recommendation to get you started this
one here dead mountain really top story
really great audiobook